JOCELYN BECKER: If you want
to be a professional Android
developer, it's critical to know
how many people use your app,
and how they use it.
For that, you need
Google Analytics.
Take this course, created
by Udacity in collaboration
with Google, to learn how to
integrate Google Analytics
into your Android app.
Packed with practical
help and code samples,
the course shows
just how easy it
is to find out
where in the world
people use your app,
which activities they use,
and even how many people
are using the app right now.
You'll discover that it takes
only a few lines of code
to track your users' locations,
languages, events, shopping
behavior, and much more.
You'll also learn how to use
Google Tag Manager to update
your app without needing
to redeploy the APK
and to manage all your
Google Analytics code tags.
Get started now, at
udacity.com/google.